Bonamassa backbench conservative MP
tipped as a possible future party leader
a former soldier who fought in
Afghanistan more than once
and now one of a handful of Tory MPs
taking on the prime minister on
universal credit mister matter a very
good morning to you good morning our
let's start shall we with with with with
universal credit it has proved to be
something of a thorn in the government
side for some time now and it appears to
be building to a head I mean simply put
what are your concerns with the scheme
well mark my concerns have always been
the same really I think universal credit
as a poverty fighting tool it's really
important in place like Plymouth where
the benefits culture has you know
transformed our city is really taken
away ambition and you know opportunities
for young people universal credit it's
going to tackle that but we just could
be so careful about how it comes in
there are a couple of key areas that
I've been concerned around and I you
know I haven't changed my tune on that I
think the phone number was you know bit
of an arrow really and the seven-day
wait this that's built in making us six
weeks before someone gets their first
payment I think is it is quite difficult
to ask people to do I mean that the
Prime Minister was asked of her
assessment of of whether or not the
system was correct this is what she had
to say in her words it's a system that
is working yeah Jim lovely right a
monster bleah that's not the case well
it is a fifth of people do not receive
their money within that six so if you
look at if you look at the statistic
from where this has been rolled out and
absolutely granted that these were
around single people living on their own
it's a less complicated scenario it is
working in terms of in terms of you know
getting people into work which is what
this is about the single biggest factor
in improving life chances in vulnerable
people is getting people into work so it
is working there are areas where it
could work better and the government's
listening on this you know we've seen
the advances of the others in the
government is listening when you went to
see the Prime Minister about this you've
been quite vocal about your concerns
about the system the rollout of
universal credit you had that meeting
and you seem to be a bit more sanguine
about it today I mean what what
concessions did the Prime Minister
look now that was a private meeting with
Prime Minister I'm looking again to that
my but it's why a that she offered you
something no it's not fair to say that I
had a conversation with the Prime
Minister and that's a private
conversation my concerns around this
have always been the same around the two
particularly the two issues I've just
mentioned to you there and yes you know
we have seen movement on the phone line
which is good
we may see movement on four to six weeks
no one's giving me that steer but you
know at the end of the day this is a
modern compassionate conservative party
that wants to get these things right
it's not sort of fingers in the air time
and just just crack on with it
the government is listening you know
David Gork and Damien have you know
we've done a lot of work on this they
are listening same-day advances coming
out the system is changing as we roll it
out but what we mustn't do is stop it
going because this is going to be the
single biggest tool in fighting poverty
and constituencies like mine well let's
do without that that will three four
five number yeah we are told no by the
end of the month that won't be a thing
of the past but what strikes me is that
somewhere in Whitehall there is a
minister that signed off on that I think
it's a little bit unfair because I think
a lot of the phone numbers are like that
I don't think there is a minister who
sat there and gone yes this is a
particularly good idea if you on the
phone you know well yes but there's a
lot there's a lot that goes on I think
you know University says yeah these well
it's actually the same as other phone
lines to deal with other issues and the
same rates that you would have to phone
your local MP for surgery upon so let's
not pretend it's some great conspiracy
it's something that should have been
corrected it has been corrected and
that's you know that's what the
government does in my experience I've
only been there two years but it's not
it's not an effort to sort of just
implement a policy that's going to have
a bad effect on the country they want to
get this right David Gork is working
really hard to get this right and we've
got to be honest and give them credit
for that and actually go with the
program if you disagree with the deal
three four five number four universal
credit you should presumably then
disagree with it elsewhere government
well I think that you know these lines
that that we're asking people
particularly around the DWP to get in
touch and and try and correct issues
with their benefits you know these
aren't really vulnerable people for whom
you know they'll be on pay-as-you-go
contracts they're not going to have
access to free phone calls yeah we've
got to think a bit more carefully on
that absolutely but you know is this a
deliberate sort of attempt to make
people pay to get in touch with deed
IPE I think that's bit forfeit but just
sticking on this topic of universal
credit I mean as you say that there is
concern there are concerns about the
demand arrears there are concerns about
the the week waiting period there are
concerns that people are not being made
aware of the fact that you know funds
can be made in advance if if they are
necessary I mean you know we're not
talking about a pilot or you know
changing policemen's helmets Yale or
while you know changing the speed limit
on you know roadworks and motorways
we're talking about a system then in
essence if it doesn't work takes food
out of the mouths of children so it's
what the assurances did you receive from
the Prime Minister in your meeting that
the system come on look I'm not going to
change my tune on this it's a program in
the Prime Minister and we're not gonna
go into that well I bet this is situates
the concerns what reassurances have you
received from the Prime Minister that
this system well yeah it's not a
conversation with Prime Minister I'm
confident that this government is
listening if they weren't I would say
something about it if if the government
wasn't working hard to make these
adjustments to make this actually work I
would say something about it but that's
not the case and they have moved on this
stuff we've got to deal with this in the
realms of reality they have introduced
even same-day advances for those who
have no money whatsoever so this policy
is changing but we cannot stop it we've
got to introduce it because ultimately
it's improving lives and constituencies
like mine I've had the universal credit
no not not real its ugly head
I presume many people would have
actually thought this to be a pretty
good week for the Prime Minister in
terms of the noises emerging from
Brussels on Brett said I mean are you
pleased with the way the negotiations
are going I didn't particularly take
view on the negotiations because I'm not
one of these who thinks we should sort
of comment on everything that happens
actually I think I'm not we have I'm
noticing okay we have we're going
through brexit a really really difficult
process we've got to get it right but
you know and so whilst I subscribe to
this idea you can't go out trying to get
a no deal right there's no point going
in and saying that we're happy to take
whatever comes because we're leaving
anyway
at the end of the day the Prime Minister
David Davis Boris and the team they've
got a responsibility to get a deal for
people who voted for brexit that's the
key people voted for this vision and we
have to deliver that and I think we
should back the Prime Minister and get
on with it rather than picking at the
bones all the time I mean would you vote
against a inaud
brexit I mean would you vote with the
Labour Party to ensure that the Commons
gets a final say on the deal no I would
Ann I would I would vote you know the UK
has voted to lead the European Union you
know I think one of the things that got
me into politics is that we treat you
know I did feel like we treated people
like there was stupid previously and now
people are saying well they didn't know
what they were voting for they did know
what they were voting for and you can't
have a referendum and then go back on it
we now have to unite as one team and
deliver on that promise of leaving the
European Union and go on to what the
Conservative Party stands where
afterwards that's what people want you
know they want to know how we're going
to fund the House service they want to
know how we're going to increase the
life chances of our most vulnerable and
constituencies like Plymouth and you
know whilst brexit drowns it all out I'm
afraid that's not what people want from
politics and we've got to do better
actually talking about the reason that
the reasons behind you your move into
politics I mean you said once that you
got fed up with the difference between
what people say in the Commons and the
platitudes that come out on on
Remembrance Day
I mean arguably as regards our armed
forces and things have gotten worse
since you got into politics what do you
think they've got worse I think it's a
journey I make no bones about it we're
not where I want to be
I've worked extremely hard on the
veterans piece and actually the people
who work day-in day-out in veterans care
trying to get this right and yes I feel
the government could have and should
have done more but you know events have
kind of overtaken us in that way and
brexit dominates the bandwidth and I get
that but we need to talk about as a
party what we look like after brexit and
I hope the veterans care and you know
being a part of defence means something
what well on the cleanup to be a party
of defence I mean I mean do you consider
the Conservatives to be bound by their
manifest or commitment to increase
defense spending above inflation yes I
do I saw Michael Fallon last week and he
mentioned that again I don't expect that
to change that is a commitment that
people voted for the Conservative Party
and this 2% argument noid is a bit of a
herring in the wind really because you
can't just get a level of GDP spent to
it and then think of things right it's
got to be done around capable mean I
mean so Michael has suggested that it
now is the time for us to see respect
above the 2% level but you know we
learned from the Sunday Telegraph spend
farmer this morning the Treasury is
blocking the manifest or commitment to
increase spending above inflation now if
that were to happen I mean
that's that's pretty fundamental failure
isn't it on the part of the party to
live up to commitments look that's not
something I'm going to support people
voted for a Conservative government and
part of that was a point 5% increase
above inflation we need to see that
because I think defense spending is too
low I think if you look at both the
threats that we're currently facing
which by Michaels own admission of have
developed significantly in last year's
and brexit what the UK looks like after
brexit there is an increased vote for
our armed forces and we got a funder I
mean things have changed somewhat since
your taming back then there were real
concerns about kit those are certainly
not to the same extent that they once
were but the concern appears to be the
number of people that we actually have
in uniform at the moment yeah but again
numbers is a bit of a red herring it's
about capabilities right what people can
do and what we can ask because you are
like no they are links but they're also
not linked so you've got the technology
and what we can enable people to do you
look at these type 26 frigates yes we've
got less of them that they're infinitely
more capable and actually you know we've
got to have an educated debate around
this it's got to be about capabilities
what we can achieve how far we can
project our forces but we've got to ask
what we want from our armed forces as a
country and crucially what we don't want
and that's what we haven't had a
discussion about still you of all people
know that the significance of the chain
of commands of following orders I mean
what would you think of a leader that
that tolerated open insurrection that we
our orders weren't followed
you might notice I use the feminine
there ya know I don't really buy into
that because look it breaks its enormous
ly difficult thing and I actually think
every government needs someone like
Philip Hammond in the Treasury someone
like Boris he's got a view someone like
Theresa keeping her hand on the tiller
the answer is probably somewhere in the
middle I'm I haven't got a problem with
it I do think you know I would suggest
that you know working as a team is the
only way we're going to solve this
particular team apart leaders though
doesn't a team does require leaders and
Therese is doing a good job and that you
use the enemy he's not the enemy well
how do you view it then I'm sorry I'm
being slightly facetious but in the
sense that you know we have to resume it
at the moment struggling to to keep a
lid on you know some members of the
cabinet I'm sure she would prefer them
to be quiet from time to time I mean the
characterization of the EU is the enemy
may not be you reviewed but the
characterization of some of the people
sitting or in the cabinet table as
enemy I mean it's it's demonstrably true
I don't think it's demonstrable 'true I
would say in fairness I think you know
in organizations where I've worked
before you know the teamwork is has been
something that I found particularly
lacking and particularly disappointing
actually I think when your leader has a
particularly difficult time actually
that's when you become more resilient
more disciplines you work harder as a
team to achieve the outcome you're
trying to do you know at the end of the
day we're sent here by people who voted
for us to get an outcome it's not about
us and the sort of dynamics going on
within the year within the cabinet so
yes now I accept what you're saying on
that front but I think Theresa's a good
Prime Minister and look we need to get
on deliver brexit that is what people
want on the doors in places like
Plymouth we need to deliver that and
then get on to what being in the
Conservative Party actually means beyond
that do you aspire to lead when there
are many who suggest that we should
perhaps skip the generation in the
conservative I've got a very busy seat
down in Plymouth and I like getting on
with that thanks no I'm sure you do
indeed there Johnny Marr so many thanks
for being with us